Esta es otra bofetada a Joe biden por
parte de la mayoría conservadora en la
Corte Suprema de Justicia 6 de 9 jueces
declararon inválida una de las promesas
de campaña del presidente cuando fue
elegido en 2020 la condonación parcial
de la deuda estudiantil el gobierno
perdonaría aproximadamente 430 mil
millones de dólares en préstamos
federales borrando por completo la deuda
de 20 millones de prestatarios la
pregunta aquí no es hay que hacer algo
sino quién tiene la autoridad para
hacerlo y uno de los mayores poderes del
Congreso es el control de la cartera
para los magistrados designados por
George www Bush y Donald Trump la
cancelación de la deuda no respetaría la
separación de poderes y fue una de las
medidas sociales emblemáticas planteadas
por biden en agosto pasado biden
confirmó la eliminación de 10 mil
dólares para prestatarios que ganaran
menos de 125.000 al año y hasta 20 mil
dólares para estudiantes becados el
presidente estadounidense expresó
inmediatamente su decepción y propuso
nuevas vías para lidiar la deuda
estudiantil
sé que millones de estadounidenses están
decepcionados desalentados y enojados
por esta decisión sobre la deuda
estudiantil y tengo que decir que yo
también anteriormente establecimos un
límite los estudiantes prestatarios sólo
podían pagar más del 10% de sus ingresos
para pagar la deuda mi administración
reducirá eso al 5%
la deuda estudiantil preocupa a 43
millones de estadounidenses y a menudo
asciende a decenas o incluso cientos de
miles de dólares para cada uno de ellos
tras el anuncio de la Corte Suprema los
sindicatos de estudiantes protestaron
frente al edificio un día antes el
máximo tribunal estadounidense tomó otra
decisión ultraconservadora la
cancelación de la discriminación
positiva en las universidades que
garantizaba el acceso de las minorías a
la educación superior